it wasn't about recreating the making of
a film that you couldn't touch that
psycho is a masterwork what we were
trying to do is sort of go behind it see
it from different angles and kind of
explore this unbelievable partnership
and collaboration and that was the
emotional core of it it's very rare that
you're able to stand in a dressing room
I know it's a black suit I know we
remember a man Hitchcock we min we
remember him when we think of his films
so already he's part of that and then
you think of him as you said walking
into the silhouette so in the dressing
room here cut here he is and as he
becomes Hitchcock you see that it's
Hopkins as Hitchcock and then he goes to
the set and he speaks as out as
Hitchcock he's with a cast even someone
like Scarlett Johansson who becomes a
character and then yet another character
playing that and you would think that
this is going to go further and further
away but it doesn't because our memories
are we carry it with us and so the
exactitude even though there's still
very much their own people but what it
when you really knew what was happening
was at the end of the shooting day and
that's you had been accustomed to
hearing Hitchcock to seeing what how he
had become the man even when he wasn't
directing and then as you want as it
right after one says wrap then you see
this man very well dressed substantially
smaller walk to a beautiful car and get
into it and then you realize that that's
Hopkins as Hopkins and it's it's why
we're in the business you know we
weren't making a Hitchcock film we
weren't remaking psycho it was nice to
know that we not only
you know I couldn't use we couldn't
design shots that were mimicking any
shots from the actual film and in a way
that was very freeing because all I had
to do was cut for the story and the
emotion which is you know that's how you
get a good story and you know obviously
there were beautiful shots that were
designed that were Hitchcockian you know
where or you know kind of suspenseful
moments where there scares in the movie
and I loved all that the darkness but
there was also a lot of humor and you
know and it was important for us to keep
it entertaining and keep the pace moving
we went into it not knowing what format
we were going to shoot with we we did
film test and digital test with the
prosthetics you know the fear being of
course digital enhances any perfections
that you might find in stuff and so that
was a great concern of ours plus the
notion that it's sacrilegious to shoot a
Hitchcock movie digitally but in the end
you know he was one of the more
progressive filmmakers we've ever had
and if that technology had appeared at
his time he probably would have been the
first person to embrace it as you see in
all the experiment experimentation that
he did throughout his whole career you
know not all of it work but most of it
was pretty brought us you know such such
a memorable moments in filmmaking
history and so after the long process
and coming to a conclusion about the
speed that we had a shoot in the the
cost advantages it just became an easy
choice for us to me and we examined both
and actually when we did the red epic
camera and the 35 mil next to each other
there was perhaps a one percent
difference because Jeff he won't say it
but he's a master of backlight and he's
so brilliant at making the digital
camera feel like film but and I think
the one percent difference was the
romance in my heart you know it really
wasn't a tremendous difference and you
know we shot this movie for no money in
35 days you know with no additional
photography so we you know things like
shooting on digital really allowed us
really to have more time with the actors
and ultimately we made that decision I
think it was the right one
because we just had it was just much
more efficient for us to do that and
frankly we didn't have the choice you
know to do all the band into one
consider this but the amount of time we
had with no visual effects planned at
the end and shooting you know somebody
in prosthetics for ninety percent of the
scenes you know to be able to see it
there and throw everybody to collaborate
and understand what we're going against
and what the obstacles on what worked
and didn't work it just didn't seem like
it was an easy choice for us to make